-Our next guest
is a talented actress
you know from her work
in "Bring It On",
"Being Mary Jane,"
and "The Inspection."
She stars in the third season
of "Truth Be Told,"
which is streaming
on Apple TV+,
with new episodes
released on Fridays.
Let's take a look.
-The superintendent shut me down
from asking questions at school
or even acknowledging
anything's wrong.
All the memorials around town,
they're all for Emily.
It's like Drea
didn't even exist.
I need to act.
♪♪
-You are.
With those bright young minds
you mold.
-Well, what use are their minds
if I can't keep
their bodies safe?
-Please welcome back to the show
Gabrielle Union, everyone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
It's so wonderful
to have you back.
-Thank you.
That was a very warm welcome.
-Yeah, it's a very warm crowd
tonight.
-Yes.
-This is --
It's a very intense show.
This is the third season
of a show.
Octavia Spencer
plays a crime podcaster.
You play a principal
in an area
where there's a lot of kids
being trafficked.
It must be a very intense thing
to take on.
-Incredibly intense.
-And how was the --
I know you've worked
with Octavia Spencer before.
That must make it
a little easier
to take on material like this.
-Yeah, there's no way I could
do this show without Octavia.
We have been friends
literally forever.
Over -- well over 20 years.
'Cause it's crazy
'cause we're only 27.
[ Laughter ]
But we've friends for so long.
We started on a show called
"City of Angels."
-Oh, yeah.
-And it was me and Octavia
and Viola Davis
and Maya Rudolph,
who before she went off to do
that show that you guys do.
-It did not go well for her.
-You know,
I think it worked out.
-But, yeah, we all met
on that show and bonded.
And, you know, from there,
that trust grew.
So when she hit me and was like,
"I have a great opportunity
for you to join season 3
of 'Truth be Told,'
but it's some
really tough material.
But I think you are uniquely
prepared for this."
And when I read the script,
I was like,
"This is gonna be a gut punch."
Every day, you know,
it's gonna be
a little triggering
or a lot triggering.
But for the greater good
of getting --
like, to create
a bigger platform
to let more people know
that human trafficking,
sexual trafficking
is a global pandemic.
And when Black and Brown girls
go missing,
we do not have the resources
or the media attention.
And we are often demonized
and sort of --
are held complicit
in our own abuse.
And just trying to, you know,
recenter the focus
on the most marginalized
of the marginalized.
-Before you became an actor,
you actually were thinking about
being a lawyer.
-Yeah.
-Which just seems very similar
to what you were just
talking about.
How far down the line
did you go with is that?
-Well, you know, I, um...
[ Laughter ]
The thing about
standardized testing...
[ Laughter ]
I was studying for the LSATs
and not doing well at all.
And I got an internship
at a modeling agency
at the same time
as I was taking these LSATs.
And when my modeling agency,
you know, gig internship ended,
they were like,
"Would you ever consider
being one of our girls"?
And I'm looking at the LSATs
that I'm doing terribly at
or being in a Tupac video,
and I was like, "I..."
[ Laughter ]
-I gotta be honest, even if
you were crushing the LSATs...
[ Laughter ]
-I'm going with Tupac.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. So, I went into
the entertainment business,
and I kind of left
the dream of law behind.
-Now, you have a 4-year-old,
and I know it's very early
to tell, but there maybe
is a bit of entertainer in her.
-Oh, a lot of entertainer
in her.
-She gave a -- now, I have a
6-year-old, I have a 4-year-old.
I can't imagine either of them
having the wherewithal
or the nerve to give a toast
at my birthday party.
But your 4-year-old
gave a toast?
-Oh, a full toast.
Like, she has --
Like she's Iyanla.
So, this is, like --
We're in Africa.
It's late.
We're in Tanzania.
And she was like,
"Mommy, you are worthy."
And I was like...
[ Laughter ]
"How do you know I struggle
with feelings of worthlessness?"
[ Laughter ]
Like...
But she never turns down --
-On a microphone?
-On a microphone
in front of a crowd.
-Planned, or did she just kinda
go up and ask the emcee,
"I'd love to say a few words"?
-Well, anytime a --
Anytime a microphone comes out,
she's like,
"Yes, I'd like to have a word."
[ Laughter ]
-And so we're like, "Kaav,
what would you like to say?"
And we're thinking it's gonna be
some cutesy toddler
"Happy birthday."
But, she was like,
"And for my third point..."
[ Laughter ]
And she had like, you know,
the Dead Sea Scrolls
of points she wanted to make.
But, no, she's very articulate,
and she loves to public-speak
and sing and do all the things.
-That is a huge thing.
Because I think,
even for people --
even for children who to go on
to be performers,
they have to get over that
public-speaking thing first.
So the fact
that she's already there...
-Oh, no,
she's ready to do press.
-She's like, "Hey, Seth.
Anyway, you are worthy."
[ Laughter ]
"For my next song..."
-My kids once very sweetly,
right before bed said,
"One day,
you'll be worthy, Dad,"
and I thought that was nice.
[ Laughter ]
-They said, "One day."
-Gives me something to aim for.
-Now, you are married to --
I know he's a former athlete,
but every time I see
the two of you together,
I just want to say,
"Two fashion icons."
-He's cute.
-All right, that's Dwyane Wade.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, you know, --
And I'm wondering what life --
And I know he's still involved
in sports ownership,
but do you, as a family,
do you yourself still watch
and root for sports,
post-playing career?
-Oh, yes.
-All right.
-I have a problem.
I become everybody's Mama June.
[ Laughter ]
So, we have, like --
We have a suite at SoFi,
so we watch the Chargers
and the Rams.
And I have to say,
the Rams with Odell?
All the women in my group chat
are like, "I am a Rams fan."
[ Laughter ]
But, I'm like, "Girl,
you are an Odell fan."
No one comes that early.
But they're like,
"He's stretching."
[ Laughter ]
"Get those hammies, Odell."
But, yeah.
But this year, not as much.
And I grew up in the Bay Area.
I'm from Omaha, Nebraska,
where we don't have
a professional team.
-Yeah.
-But everyone's Cornhusker fans.
But growing up in the Bay Area,
you're a 49er fan.
So we've been watching
the 49ers.
-That's nice,
to have a rooting interest
going into championship weekend.
That's a nice feeling.
-Well, again,
with the group chat.
So, apparently,
the group chat is all --
throwing all of our weight
behind Jalen Hurts.
-Oh, interesting.
He's the handsome this year?
-Apparently, he is.
He -- He does well for himself.
[ Laughter ]
I'd like to go home
to a happy home,
so I'm not gonna comment there.
[ Laughter ]
But the streets are saying...
-The streets.
Look, you're hearing things,
you're not saying things.
You're hearing things.
-For the older kids,
he's like the new Warren Moon.
[ Laughter ]
-For the way older kids,
or I guess just me.
-You got me.
-I got you. I totally --.
And you mentioned you're
from Omaha, and a big family.
-Very big.
-So a lot of family
still in Omaha.
-Yeah.
The bulk of our family
is still in Omaha.
We have the largest Black family
in the state of Nebraska.
-Oh, my goodness.
Congratulations.
-I don't know how hard that is.
[ Scattered applause ]
-Okay.
[ Both laugh ]
-But one of the largest
in the Midwest.
And this -- this last summer,
we had our 105th annual
family reunion.
-105th annual fam--
That is an incredible number.
-Yes, we're called
the Dozens of Cousins.
-Dozens of Cousins.
-Yeah, the Bryant-Fisher family.
-Now, you're doing something
that I find --
I actually find very impressive
and I hope does not come to pass
for 50 years from now.
-Uh-oh.
-You are planning
your own funeral.
-Oh, yes.
-Okay. This is something --
-You have to.
-When did you decide
to start putting
the planning into it?
-Going to a lot of bad funerals,
and it's...
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's kind of like when me and
my husband were getting married,
like, the couple summers
before we got married,
we were at --
at other people's weddings,
like, "Not that, never that,
nope, nope, nope."
So it led me to, like, think,
"I feel like I need to plan
my funeral down to,
like, the smallest detail."
So I've chosen
all of the sexiest photos.
I don't want like --
If I die at 88,
I don't want to be 88
on the program.
You give me --
You give me my thirst traps.
[ Laughter ]
All my best material.
But, like, I've got playlists
that they have.
Like, food.
Like, I want a good funeral.
-That's great.
-Yeah.
-And now, when you mention
a playlist,
are you constantly editing it?
-You have to.
-If you hear a new banger,
are you like,
"Oh, that's gotta be..."
-Now we have a lot of Beyoncé
from the latest.
-Yeah.
-You have to constantly update.
-Do you let her know?
Are you like, "Good news.
You're on of my funeral mix."
-Listen, when I showed up
at her birthday, and I'm like,
"It's a circle of life,
and I just want you to know
that when it's the end for me,
you'll also be there."
[ Laughter ]
-That does seem like a thing
that might be hard to hear,
which is like, "I'm gonna
play you at my funeral."
[ Laughter ]
But there you go.
I think that's very nice
that you put that work into it
because I think that --
you know, obviously,
when that happens, you,
for your loved one
that recently passed,
you want to make sure
you do it the way they did.
-And I think we think
we are closer to people
than we actually are.
-Yeah.
-Have you ever heard yourself
described by a family member?
And you're like,
"Do you know me?"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Like, at what point
do you know me?
-I know,
based on what I've heard,
your daughter will be there
being like, "She was worthy."
[ Laughter ]
You know what?
That's what you should do.
You should also write
the speeches people give
at your funeral.
Just like, "Don't go off book."
-Yeah, like,
"I've prepared some remarks."
[ Laughter ]
Read that.
-Thank you so much
for being here.
It's always such a pleasure
to see you.
You guys,
that's Gabrielle Union.
"Truth Be Told"
is streaming on Apple TV+
with new episodes
released on Fridays.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."